اسامه ما الجديد لديك هل الاعداد في تزايد
بالنسبه للذين يحاولون مغادره اذا السودان
عبر بورسودان
نعم نحن داخل نادي الموالي البحريه
قباله السواحل ميناء بورسودان هذه واحد من
المراكز الانتظار التي ربما يكتظ فيها
الاف المنتظرين فيما يتعلق بعمليه اجلائهم
وهم جنسيات مختلفه بطبيعه الحال ينتظرون
هنا في هذه اللحظات
ويتقاطرون من الخرطوم ومن اماكن بعيده
طلبا
للوصول الى مدينه
بارسودان حتى يتسنى لهم الانتهاء من عمليه
اجلائهم هذه مجموعه كبيره من الجنسيات
المختلفه يعني
في هذه اللحظات تنتظر عمليه اجلائهم
وتنتظر كذلك يعني
انتهاء من الاجراءات التي ربما في هناك
ربما صعوبات تواجه هؤلاء الذين ربما يتم
اجلائهم هل تواجهكم في عمليه الاجزاء
صعوبات كثيره اولها قال لسياده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه طلبت منا ان ناتي لو كان
بورقه اثبات شخصيه ويقوموا بترحيلنا خمسه
ايام هالشيء ما صار عم نعاني من نقص بكل
شيء وحالي مزريه نساء اطفال شيوخ عجز
وتعودنا على المملكه انه تكون دائما
للعطاء والخير والانسانيه وخصوصا سمول
الملك محمد بن سلمان طيب بالنسبه
هلا خمس ايام
سوريين ما طلع منها حدا
نحن 3000 سوري هون يعني خدمات صفر تحت
الشمس تحت المطر يعني ما في شيء عائلات
اطفال مرضانه نحن شباب ما فينا نتحمم ما
في مي ما في حمامات ما في شيء اي مقومات
الحياه يكثر خيرها الحكومه السودانيه
ومستضيفتنا بس هاي امكانياتها امكانيات
تعبان ونحن شعب تعبنا طيب فيما يتعلق
بعمليه فيما يتعلق بعمليه الاله هي طبعا
لا تزال مستمره عبر مطار
بورسودان الدولي وعبر ميناء طور سودان
ولكن الاعداد كما تشاهدون انها كثيره
ومتزايده بطبيعه الحال ولكن هناك ربما
تعقيدات رغم ان السلطات السودانيه هنا
تقوم بعمليه الاجلاء والتسجيل الاسماء
وعمليه
كما ان هناك اعداء كبيره من السودانيين
ايضا عالقونا ولم يستطيعوا حتى هذه اللحظه
الوصول الى الميناء او الانتهاء من عمليه
من عمليه الاجلاء بعضهم مهندسون بعضهم
اطباء وبعضهم اساتذه ربما هناك بعض
التعقيدات تصاحب عمليه اجلائهم ما هي
عمليه الصعوبات التي تواجهك في عمليه
السفر السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
انا دكتور كباش خاطر كباش الجامعه الطائف
وصلنا الى بورسودان من يوم الثلاثاء
واتينا هنا الى النادي وطلب منا ان تسجيل
اسماء بكل الاساتذه الجامعات مختلفه
الجامعات وحقيقه فعلا تم تسجيل كل
الاساتذه بما فيهم عائلات وسلمنا الكشف
وطلبوا منها المعلوماتي لليوم الثاني
الاستلام الجوازات فلما رجعنا رجعوا لنا
الجوازات كلها بدون تاشيرات والحقيقه احنا
يعني ما عندنا اي وسيله اخرى يعني حتى في
مجموعه مننا تاشيراتهم هتنتهي بعد يوم
ويومين وهذا الحاصل يعني وحتى الان احنا
ما ندري انه يعني ما في مواقف تجاريه ما
في اي احد يعني يعجلوه فجايسين يعني بهذا
الشكل يعني طيب شكرا يبدو ان هناك تعقيدات
ربما تواجه بعض
الذين يريدون ان يسافروا من مدينه
بورسودان ولكن هنا عمليه الانتظار لا تزال
ولا يزال الذين يريدون الاجلاء يتقاتلون
نحو مدينه بورسودان الجنسيات مختلفه
ورعايه من دول متعدده بطبيعه الحال في
هناك اسر هناك اطفال وهناك نساء ينتظرون
لايام هنا في هذه اللحظات ولكن يعني
عمليات المبادرات الانسانيه المجتمعيه
التي يقوم بها بعض الشباب في مدينه
بورسودان ربما تخفف وضعه هذه الظروف
الانسانيه التي يعيشها هؤلاء المنتظرون
رغم ان عمليات الاجلاء لا تزال مستمره عبر
ميناء بورسودان وعبر مطار سودان الدولي
صباح اليوم
نعم ما كان يتم في الايام السابقه هو
ثلاثه في عمليه اجلام بمجرد ان تصل هذه
الاعداد الى اماكن الاجلاء وخاصه نتحدث
هنا عن المواطنين الاجانب من دول غربيه ما
الذي جعل الوضع يختلف
ربما ما يعقد الامر اكثر فاكثر هو استمرار
تدفقات هؤلاء الذين يريدون عمليه الاجلاء
نحو مدينه بارصودان عمليه السفر من
الخرطوم ومن مدن اخرى طبعا مستمره مع
استمرار المواجهات ودخول هذه الاشتباكات
المسلحه ما بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في الخرطوم يعني ربما تعقد
هذه العمليات العسكريه تحرك هؤلاء الذين
يريدون عمليه الهلال ووصولهم الى مدينه
بورسودان تشاهدون اعداد من الناس وامتعه
متفرقه في اماكن متفرقه وعمليات انتظار لا
تزال موجوده لاعداد كبيره من الجنسيات
المختلفه منهم من سافر ومنهم من يبقى حتى
هذه اللحظات ولا احد يستطيع منهم كما
ذكروا هم
من الجنسيات العربيه اكثر منهم من
الجنسيات الاوروبيه
اغلب هؤلاء الذين يوجدون في هذا المكان هم
من الجاليات العربيه منهم سوريون منهم
يمنيون ومنهم سودانيون اصلا هناك ايضا
سودانيون عالقونا جاؤوا الى من بعض الدول
العربيه
ويعني قبل الاحداث الاخيره
ولكن علقوا بسبب هذه الاحداث ولم يتمكنوا
من السفر ولكن يحاولون في هذه اللحظات
وجود ايجاد فرصه لهم منهم من سافر بالفعل
وبعد ايام من وجود هنا ومنهم من ينتظر حتى
هذه اللحظات ويتحدثون عن تعقيدات يعني
تصاحب عمليه
اجلائهم يعني يجعلهم ينتظرون عده ايام حتى
يتمكنوا من الوصول الى البحر
لاكتمال عمليه السفر بالنسبه اليهم